un petit tour de table mais papine n'a
pas le droit de participer si je vous
dis trap et talent humoristique quel nom
vous vient à l'esprit un prof à mini
peut-être
autour de l'humour
Jamel Debbouze le premier mot le premier
nom qui a qui vous vient à l'esprit
ce qu'on parle à présent de talents trap
chaud qui se déroule le disais en début
d'édition ce mercredi 24 mai c'est au
Conservatoire de Musique et de Danse de
Trappes le début est à 20h30 vous le
voyez sur cette affiche donc c'est un
tremplin humour vous lisez tout à
l'heure papi mettant en lumière les
humoristes locaux un territoire de 50
ans en Yvelines quand même faut le dire
avec un réservoir énorme de talent Jamel
Debbouze Sophia Aram Arnaud de sa mère
Laurie péreth ça Doumbia en les cité
tout à l'heure comment vous expliquer
qu'il y a une telle richesse de talent
sur le territoire je suis là c'est ça
l'explication c'est c'est on en parle
aussi pour le sport c'est pareil c'est
comment on accompagne des des jeunes que
ce soit quelle que soit le talent
sportif on en reparlera avec les nos
camarades tout à l'heure mais et je
crois qu'il y a un terroir ici
qui est fait autour de l'improvisation
théâtrale aussi qu'on a développé de
façon massive dans les collèges de
depuis 30 ans puisqu'on a fêter les
critères de la fêter ses 30 ans donc il
y a la fois ça et puis effectivement
l'émergence d'une singularité d'un seul
coup quelqu'un qui veut aller un peu
plus loin comment je l'accompagne parce
que on parle de Jamel mais il a fallu
six ans pour que Djamel arrive à là où
il devait être c'est à dire de
d'exploser donc pendant ces 5 6 ans
c'est comment effectivement bon à papi
ou un autre mais comment on accompagne
effectivement un talent émergé et il y a
besoin de temps de rencontre avec le
public et c'est ce qu'on a décidé de
faire avec la ville de Trappes c'est de
créer de recréer cet espace là parce que
je dis Omer écoute Ali écoute je si je
suis là moi ce que je sais faire c'est
accompagner des futurs talents donc
pourquoi et pourquoi pas sur ce terroir
trappiste mais voilà il y a pratique et
qui est qui est Guyancourt parce qu'elle
a vu le dernier talent crabe chaud et
donc elle est venue me voir et puis
c'était intéressant ce qu'elle avait à
nous dire je dis bah écoute ouais bah là
dans le prochain juillet et on travaille
dessus donc c'est l'idée pourquoi
proposer c'est l'accompagnement avant
tout c'est l'accompagnement avec un
point d'État un point d'étape qui est
celui de se retrouver de confronter un
public et puis se donner à voir se faire
entendre et puis qu'est-ce qui va y
avoir de particulier dans dans ce que la
personne va vous dire et si elle peut
être drôle alors là c'est carrément le
pompon donc
c'est un vrai bonheur de pouvoir mettre
ça en place attrape pour moi ça a
beaucoup de sens puisque tout le travail
que qu'on a pu faire c'est 30 dernières
années bah ça continue et je suis encore
là toujours là la transmission que
s'est-il passé avant la soirée comment
et ont été sélectionnés les talents qui
seront sur scène mercredi bah je vous ai
dit à la fois il y a quelqu'un comme
pratique qui a vu le dernier et puis qui
est venu me voir à la près il m'a dit
comment et donc du coup je l'ai reçu à
Trappes pour pouvoir travailler avec
elle sur son sur ces 10 minutes qu'elle
va faire et puis après certains c'est
des connaissances donc il y a des gens
qui sont plus rodés qui ont qui ont de
l'expérience comme Christine Berrou qui
va venir
après c'est les réseaux c'est aussi
effectivement je me suis fait un petit
nom aussi dans le milieu de l'humour
donc les gens pour eux c'est important
de venir attraper ça parce que c'est là
où il s'est passé plein de choses donc
même pour les dans le milieu du l'humour
bah trap reste une référence donc de
venir partager le plateau avec des
débutants pour des confirmer c'est aussi
important ce soir là il y aura des des
premières sur scène du coup alors il y a
des premières je vous parlais de
pratique il y aurait il y aura
effectivement à la fois des gens qui ont
qui qui sont dans une phase d'émergence
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont déjà pratiqué
ils ont déjà eu des rencontres mais il
faut encore les accompagner donc donc il
y a une qui fait sa première c'est
pointille après il y a Steve ou Carla ou
Marie ça va être sa deuxième on va dire
aussi et puis qui ont une petite
actualité qui se lancent dans le métier
donc et puis après il y a Christine
Berrou qui est un peu plus de bouteilles
et voilà à chaque fois c'est
de dire il y a une progression enfin il
faut tenir c'est les métiers difficiles
où il faut s'accrocher il faut tenir il
faut manger mais bon les copains
sportifs n'oublions pas l'air c'est
pareil pour le sport donc la détermine
ne pas lâcher d'être de on enclenche
quelque chose et ben trappe sera une
étape le talent de trappe chaud on sera
une peut-être sur leur chemin et tant
mieux mais la détermination c'est pas
que dans le sport Audrey qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler tout à l'heure
pour ceux qui connaissent pas le format
ça se déroule comment concrètement la
soirée alors il y a cinq artistes et
puis les internets sont menés par moi et
Julie qui est qui est aussi la
coproductrice de de ce talent de Trapp
chaud euh et donc on va laisser 5 entre
5 et 10 minutes à chaque talent pour
pouvoir exprimer ce qu'il a à dire
ensuite on le reçoit et on fait un
débriefing avec lui non pas de ce qui
vient de se jouer mais d'où il en est
qu'est-ce qui veut défendre et tout ça
reste plus on vient pas baiser le
meilleur et tout ça il y a pas à l'issue
de la soirée vainqueur voilà il y a pas
de vainqueur mais il y a cinq talents
qui ont un peu d'espace du temps pour
pouvoir se donner à voir et
l'accompagnement se poursuit après la
soirée on imagine du coup effectivement
attrape je suis en train de faire une
pépinière donc pour certains si je peux
les accompagner plus loin et ben je le
fais avec grand bonheur donc le public
pas de roulage à jouer ne serait-ce que
découvrir ses talents finalement
découvrir des des talents et le
conservatoire est une vraie belle
coquille le son est comme c'est un
conservatoire il est très très bon donc
non c'est toujours très comment dire
c'est toujours touchant de voir aussi
des gens pour qui c'est les premiers pas
sur le plateau quoi info pratique billet
à 5 euros pour venir même pas cher pas
cher on peut le prendre à l'avance ou on
vient directement sur place on peut
aussi appeler mais on peut venir au
dernier moment en se disant tiens je
vais passer une bonne soirée et on le
disait donc tel en trap chose c'est ce
mercredi 24 mai voilà c'est tout cette
semaine voilà ça tombe très bien à deux
jours de l'événement et ça se déroule au
Conservatoire de Musique et de Danse de
trappes à partir de 20h30 merci papi
être venu en parler en plateau